daddy would have been the girl's number
one Supporter and like he said football
is freedom and the girls are actually
now free to play this beautiful game
Hawaii miss Adella there would be no
qualification in Jamaica is called a
woman's time now the woman's senior team
was disbanded due to lack of funding
there was no records team anymore
she's the one who saw the vision my
youngest son came home from school with
a flyer it was asking for support for I
think at that time was the under-17 she
funded the money and said hey you need a
women's team here's the money
boom let's make it happen we made some
calls and you know I became the
ambassador I grew up just believing I
could do whatever I wanted to do and
just to believe that these girls were
being told they cannot play and we will
not support you just because you're
female I started to get angry I wanted
them to have the opportunity to do
something that they really love plus
they're representing our country you
can't Axton to give a bigger sacrifice
[Music]
[Applause]
it is historic that Jamaica has been the
first Caribbean country to qualify for
the Women's World Cup like that's not
lost on me I think that playing in the
World Cup is like a dream you have since
you're a little girl and I think seeing
it come to fruition is amazing given the
circumstances that these girls are
coming from they have already won in my
eyes it's how we can sustain a female
program in our country in Jamaica they
call it woman's time now I'm glad it is
happening that people are not having the
conversations about women's league in
Jamaica not only Jamaica but the entire
Caribbean region and I still pinch
myself periodically my daddy he loved
the game if he didn't learn how to play
guitar he would probably be one of the
tiniest midfielder or a striker on the
field daddy would have been the girl's
number one Supporter and like he said
you know football is freedom and the
girls are actually now free to play this
beautiful game
[Music]